and so I'm all about creating those
experiences where it's like wow that was
incredible and I and I'm not at creating
anything at the same time it's more of
this idea of putting together the
perfect location with the perfect food
with the perfect like you know medicine
and group of facilitators that are going
to really bring people through a deep
transformational experience that starts
with the preparation all the way through
the end with the integration usually
working with five Meo DMT as well as
iboga but both separately so those are
two different retreat formats like for
instance with the five amel retreat we
we do purification rituals to prepare
the person to go into this deep work
with the bufo alvarius and that includes
doing two miscall so sweat lodge
traditional sweat lodge to really help
them you know kind of cleanse some
layers off to allow them to surrender
deeper into the work boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sock Ewan
we are on site of consciousness hacking
so wakened future summit we are now
going to be talking to Tricia Eastman
hello hi how are you doing such an honor
to be here such an honor to be hacking
some consciousness and exploring
psychedelic states and meditation with
you thank you so much for coming on to
the show I really appreciate it and and
that was a that was quite a well
synthesized I agree that that's but is
what is going on here it's such a great
group
Tricia's background she's the founder of
psychedelic journeys altered states the
role facilitator duty of care we're
gonna be unpacking this I'm very excited
why don't you tell us who you are and
what you represent
Wow that's a big thing so um
Who am I um I've been in the role of
medicine woman for about four and a half
years now done some very powerful
initiations
Moondance tradition work with the five
mio DMT from the bufo alvarius toad
which is also known as the Sonoran
desert toad I work with I've been
initiated in several traditions of booty
which is a a tradition indigenous
tradition from Gabon which is Central
Africa and they work with a sacrament
called iboga which is one of the most
powerful sacraments I would say as far
as shamanic as well as psychoactive
experiences very potent healing tool
also being used for addiction one of the
alkaloids in the in the plan is a very
potent healer called ibogaine and I got
my start and now begin clinic in Mexico
called crossroads four and a half years
ago and have just really been you know
number one I feel that you know it's
important to balance the sacred and the
science I feel that in our modern era we
have a lot of really beautiful wisdom
keepers that aren't gonna be on the
planet for very much longer so I'd to
bring in different elders and weave them
into the different events and things
that I do for instance I am launching a
new project a burning man called
ancestral heart where I'm gonna be
bringing two tribes from Africa from
Gabon and from Ghana to share their
traditions storytelling play music
drumming and ritual and ceremony but
nothing of course psychoactive on apply
really we want to introduce people to
the way of being and the wisdom that
comes through these beautiful elders
rather than necessarily focusing on you
know the psychoactive plants and things
like that okay four and a half years of
being a psychotherapist is that fair to
say I can't say that I'm a
psychotherapist because I have not
certified for that what I am is I help
people you know really work work through
their trauma so I definitely
we do a form of therapy but it's but
it's not in the form of you know what
you would find in a college and you
receive a certificate for it yeah this
stuff is so strange like oh you get a
certificate for this versus actually go
through the process of of doing it so
many times hundreds thousands of times
with people helping them versus having a
certificate it's kind of like yeah
there's it's kind of it's funny yeah
okay
so there's been probably what is it
hundreds of people if not maybe even a
thousand people over a thousand but over
a thousand people yeah okay whoa that's
crazy
okay so before we get to science
spirituality and the new indigenous
because that's very interesting what has
it been like working with a thousand
people well you know every single
experience I feel like we're all mirrors
of each other we're all mirrors of the
divine and I feel like each one has been
you know I like to think of it like when
babies are being born in the hospital
and you see that fresh new life that's
there that it's just so perfect and so
beautiful I feel that these processes
there's some really you know sometimes
gnarly layers that shut off and that new
person they look different I mean if you
look in like a plastic surgery office at
the before and after picture some of the
before and after pictures of iboga would
be more profound you know because that
trauma we where that that's our real
makeup like on our faces the sadness the
grief the anger all those things like we
wear that on ourselves okay and then the
process of going through a session with
someone like you that's working helping
people work through some of the trauma
or an heal yeah that when when when
working with a healer the process of
integrating that how how does that
process work when you kind of see that
what was what was being worn by someone
that
trom that was being warned that it how
does it yeah how did what does that
process look like one that it becomes
integrated and people have that fresh
baby baby face yeah I mean I just think
about like how much like mental chatter
is connected each one of those
expressions like the parts that most
people would probably say are ugly about
themselves you know that that they learn
to love them and they go through the
process of loving them through
acceptance through going through them
through feeling the feelings and then
once they've done that the energy leaves
the body and sometimes it's pretty
intense sometimes they purge it out and
they're like wow I see my dad's face and
the purge pull you know because it's
something maybe that that was some
conditioning from their father and
sometimes they just feel really sick and
then all of a sudden they burp and
they're like whoa I feel better and they
released that energy from the body
sometimes they laugh sometimes they cry
sometimes they scream outraged that
they've been holding for you know who
knows how many years where they're just
like wow and then you know once that's
gone there's just room in there and it's
quiet in there and you know it's a good
place to live and so they're happy
because of that you know there's there's
no reason not to be happy it's like
their homes been cleaned out whoa okay
what's going on in like the let's talk a
couple things here first is what's going
on on the on the physiological side
within people when they take a plan
medicine and which plan medicines are we
talking about
okay well pretty much all of them have a
story arc and the story arc can happen
really quickly or can happen really
slowly the stronger ones it usually
happens really quickly and that's why it
can be so intense for people unless
they've done a lot of other spiritual
practices or they've done a lot of other
psychedelic shamanic work before to
where they can handle that pace or
handle that depth of the pain and the
things that they have to experience so
the way it starts is phase one
is having to clean out the closet and
the closet is your skeletons in your
closet and so literally imagine
someone's going through your closet and
like hey Alan
here's a skeleton you want to keep this
skeleton or you want to get rid of it
and if you want to get rid of it all you
have to do is let go yeah like oh god
that skeletons horrible it's from the
80s cod get that thing away from me you
know that's not gonna help you get that
skeleton out of your closet
you've got to be like okay I accept that
I see that this is a skeleton but you
know I'm acknowledging what happened
what I did and I'm gonna breathe through
this I'm just gonna face it and then
guess what it goes away you have to see
it before it goes away so then you go
through that process of cleansing and
then once you're cleanse you can't get
into the spirit world
unless you're clean you can't get in
with baggage you are not allowed to
bring anything with you but your soul
and what your soul knows and so then if
you're lucky if you do a lot of good
cleaning and you let go of those
skeletons and you get to go into the
spirit world and that's usually where
you meet your soul you get insights
around your purpose and you know the
future and you know what what the
universe is all about on a bigger scale
and meet guides and all kinds of cool
stuff
whoa okay so some of the story arcs
depending on the medicines that's part
of the journey can be fast some can be
slower but almost certainly we're going
through a process of the of skeletons
yeah okay and sometimes there's also the
process of just kind of just diving into
the oneness into the unity into the
unity yeah and so okay okay so so it
depends on the medicine sometime you get
shown skeletons sometimes you go into
unity kind of just depends on the yeah
on the medicine okay
okay it seems like with 500 EMT it's
more towards say you straight to the
medicine I have another easier way I can
yes if you want to here yeah
so think of it like your chakras are an
elevator and each floor is a destination
in another dimension but your elevator
is gonna get stuck and not let you
travel if there's trauma in the way and
it gets stored on all of those floors so
as you're going through those different
floors you go up into different layers
when you get into the higher floors
that's when you start to dissolve and in
you know the term drop rejoining the
ocean which is the idea of the ocean of
consciousness where you become one with
all things and you have less of a sense
of physicality that happens once you've
made it to the sixth floor and so that's
where through the third eye the soul
leaves the body and is able to travel
and so when you go through these
different floors and the elevator you're
basically stopping and realizing some
some things you've got to resolve before
you're able to travel you know yeah
that's good stuff yeah yeah so so so we
we resolve the the traumas the skeletons
in the closet on the way up to the and
you said there's so many things that
happen and that when we do merge with
this unity when they drop merges with
the ocean that there's some sort of a
soul to whatever happens in that place
that you speak of is up to I guess
people's experiences and is there some
soaring theme that people feel when they
dissolve when they have the sore leaves
the yeah word where do they go do they
go past this 3d reality where do they go
into some other places of existence well
I can tell you from my experience and
what I've experienced
you know witnessing others and what I
experience it's very similar to the
Tibetan Book of the Dead and it's like
the same thing that happens when you go
through the birth canal when you're born
all this pressure and then also you pop
and that's basically what happens when
you pop out of the birth canal the same
thing is happening with your third eye
you're basically going through the birth
canal into the spirit world basically
into the spirit world into the spirit
what happens in the spirit world so the
way I've experienced it is there's
different layers of these ashrams of
consciousness and these are schools and
we're connected through our own galactic
ties to specific ones and then there's
also ones that we can build connections
with and so when we're going into these
different places
we're receiving I call them lake codes
which is just pure information and you
can literally download years worth of
information like what would take someone
you know the time it would take to get a
PhD within seconds you can receive like
a lifetime of information and so really
the more that you can surrender the the
the most pure point is the void and the
void is the center of the entire
universe and it's the womb of the entire
universe and if you go there then you
get the complete soul carwash so I call
it which is the reset if you go through
the womb and you're able to just be in
the complete stillness and death of it
then you come out the other side being
reborn you need to leave some stuff and
then you revisit that void you do you
revisit the void or do you just visit
once and then you Reaper reborn you can
visit it as often as you want you can
kind of carry it with you on a moment to
moment basis yeah I mean it's the point
of creation and the point of destruction
and so it's the ultimate place to go
because all things are birthed from
there so anything that you want to birth
you can go in and you can you can
rebirth through that through that place
and and then the ashrams and the
consciousness schools and being able to
you know what what is it that we are
part of an ashram and then we say like I
want to go to playground earth
go learn eighty years of stuff and then
I want to come back and go to a play at
a different place and keep learning
stuff is this kind of the process of
what is it like I think everyone has
their own path and I think some souls
will come to earth and learn specific
things and then they might go on to be a
galactic logos themselves where they
might go into one of these areas and
basically represent the essence of that
and so for us to talk about it in this
space it's very different to articulate
because the human brain is like a cache
it's not an actual knowledge system the
way that we are able to have like the
great thinkers of the world are able to
create these chords to those galactic
ashrams and so for instance Einstein all
of you know the great thinkers that have
have existed the geniuses actually did
that outside of their mind they were
thinking beyond this you know thing
that's stuck inside our school and they
realized that this is just a temporary
memory system and within this system we
actually forget a lot and we don't have
access to very much intelligence okay
this that was such a good short bit on
on okay then then you started churning
us into science and spirituality blended
together and also the indigenous okay so
when I go to like psychedelic journeys
calm and I go and I visit your page am i
what am i learning what am i signing up
for am i going to retreat centers around
the world and experiencing plant myths
and journeys with different healers is
this kind of yeah well I I'm really I'm
impassionate I feel like my life one of
my favorite things is I feel like all of
us are ultimately here to create art
like art is the highest form of
expression as a human being and so for
me I feel like my art is ceremony and
being
a healing artist I like to create
experiences that are different than
anything else you could experience and
you know when I worked in the normal
world before I was doing this work I
always had a saying that was like I
don't charge by the hour I charge by the
awesome and so I'm all about creating
those experiences where it's like wow
that was incredible and I and I'm not at
creating anything at the same time it's
more of this idea of putting together
the perfect location with the perfect
food with the perfect like you know
medicine and group of facilitators that
are going to really bring people through
a deep transformational experience that
starts with the preparation all the way
through the end with the integration
usually working with five Meo DMT as
well as iboga but both separately so
those are two different retreat formats
like for instance with the five amel
retreat we we do purification rituals to
prepare the person to go into this deep
work with the bufo alvarius and that
includes doing two miscall so sweat
lodge traditional sweat lodge to really
help them you know kind of cleanse some
layers off to allow them to surrender
deeper into the work
okay so alright I'm I'm now someone that
is wanting to sign up for some of the
psychedelic journey stuff so then am I
when I go through the the portal and end
up at one of the centers years a whole
process of even pre and even getting to
the center like there's like a bunch of
stuff that I have to do in terms of you
have to you're like you're trying to set
up this perfect ceremonial location
nutrition all the set of stuff to make
the experience exactly what it needs to
be the ah some experience and then
there's also this like intake
information that you need to know about
the person there's like so yeah so tell
us about this process so what's really
important in the process is to really
identify who are good candidates for
this work and so you know one of the
things I was talking today in my talk
about is these three spheres that I look
at with every person to make sure that
they're ready and one is their own
spiritual practices whether it's
meditation yoga whatever things are
gonna help them integrate but also the
things that are gonna help them Center
if they're having a hard time in the
experience the second sphere is the
level of trauma that they have so
whether it's high medium low because
that will also impact if they're able to
even surrender to these two powerful
medicines which many would classify is
the most powerful psychoactive medicines
on the planet and then the third is
their experience with other psychedelics
are they more of a novice they've tried
mushrooms one time in high school are
they someone who's a psycho knot or are
they someone who's done a lot of like
shamanic plant experiences such as San
Pedro or ayahuasca typically it's
someone who is on the higher experienced
level where they've had some other
shamanic experiences and they want to go
deeper they they want to do more work
and they want it to be in a really well
held can
and so those are those are the ideal and
so I look at a balance between those
three factors you know if one of them is
really off balance there needs to be a
strong foundation in the other two in
order for it to make sense for them
because we want them to have a good
experience and be able to get receive
the awesome that's waiting for them yes
yes and then what are some of the the
when you have someone go through the
process and then there may be coming in
with some sort of a deep trauma yeah so
what are some of the things that you
actually specialize in healing and
integrating related to the trauma yeah
like yeah which specific ones for those
that may be interested in in both
learning plot or as well as healing
themselves you know the way I work with
trauma is that I mean a lot of people
have really really deep trauma and you
know I've worked with people with you
know just what I would call Holocaust
survivor level trauma doctors have
classified it at that level and they
need a really gentle slow approach which
is really about powerful mirroring
because many of these people who have
deep trauma they're just running away so
deeply from their pain and their
suffering and they have good right to
you know if they with the suffering that
they're whole because that's all stored
in their body and so it's a combination
of really seeing where they're at you
know what they're comfortable with and
being able to kind of do the trauma and
I mean that as like you know like when a
woman's giving birth you know you have
those birthing contractions the same you
have when you're releasing trauma in
your body so it's just really helping
you know maybe it's holding their hand
maybe it's helping to move some energy
in the body putting some pressure on you
know a certain part of the body that is
you know where that where that trauma
stuck and then sometimes towards the end
it might be helping that person ground
by like touching their feet or you know
doing different techniques to help them
to come
into their bodies because they just
don't have those tools and so it's about
first of all giving them the confidence
to see you know because they they they
deserve it because they went through
that experience that they are able to
release that trauma that they're able to
face their shadow and their darkness but
then it's also the tools that they learn
and then also learning a new pattern of
feeling your emotions versus running
away from them so it can be really
powerful if it's done in a very soft way
and then there's a couple there's a
there's a somewhat of a routine that you
follow with with five hundred DMT and I
boga yeah you mean in terms of house
beginning to end yeah and and how yeah
beginning to end through the whole yes
was it a week is the whole five days
yeah so with the five Meo DMT I do it in
a format that I've kind of created that
I think is a really potent way of
honoring the medicine which is doing
three ceremonies over three days and as
I shared before we do the Tamez call
first and then we close it with a cacao
ceremony I kind of call it the medicines
of Mexico because we're using Mayan
cacao we're using Tamez coal which is
you know part of the mushy cat radition
that I'm initiated in and and my blood
my family line as well as the bufo
alvarius which is from Mexico too so
it's really beautiful combination and
really honoring the the lineages from
Mexico and the traditions and the
beautiful medicine which I which I love
so much
all of those modalities and then also
the iboga is done in two nights of
ceremony but we're also doing
purification rituals beforehand as well
which we do these spiritual baths which
are kind of like Olympia but it's a it's
a
designed to kind of clean you before you
go into the medicine so both are
incorporating the purification because
you don't you don't show up for the
sacred like you would you would never
show up on a date with a dirty shirt you
wouldn't want to show up in the sacred
like all dirty
so the purification rituals are really
essential for the process and that is
usually a five day process both both
retreats once five days the others
actually six days because we include
extra day on each one for rest and
integration yeah this you would show up
to the date with the dirty shirt and
yeah and you need a day of integration
at the end and you have this specific
style of ceremony for both five Meo as
well as iboga this is there's so much to
still unpack and understand oh I want to
know on an on a like a neuroscience and
physiology perspective do you know
what's going on with the heart or the
brain during the times of like seeing
the skeletons and integrating them or
during the times of bathing into the
unity like yeah what's happening yeah
and it's really interesting because when
we work with trauma we look at these
circuitry systems that are regulated by
the vagal nerve which there are several
points used in somatic therapy designed
to reroute the energy and open up the
space so that rather than working in an
amygdala based system which is the
reptilian brain you're functioning from
the frontal lobe which is more of like
an observer type aspect of of
approaching trauma you can still have a
trauma activation but instead of being
in it reliving it you're actually like
viewing it like oh this is an energy
that's leaving my body or this is
something that happened that I'm now
reappear Ian Singh but not necessarily
like having a reaction not being
reactive towards the trauma so what
happens in that process typically
whether the trauma is
being lived or whether the trauma is
being observed you're still gonna have
an elevation of the heart and a lot of
the physiological symptoms that happen
like the first time that you had the
incident happen whatever it was like
maybe you thought you were gonna die or
maybe you you felt unsafe or maybe you
were just really afraid whatever that is
maybe your heart started beating really
fast maybe you started feeling
light-headed
maybe I mean although all the symptoms
of like high levels of stress but the
difference between when you actually are
viewing it from the observer or the
frontal lobe is that you experience it
and then it's gone as we're with the
vagal nerve amygdala loop it never
releases you just keep Rhian seing it
over and over and over again and it
never leaves so it's there and it gets
reactivated so that's why it's so
important to face it and release it and
it's great to have someone there that
can do some touch that can kind of come
in your heart or you know put their hand
behind your neck and there's a point
here there's a point here and then
there's a point right there that can be
released and so the touch is really
useful because it's like okay we're
gonna release this okay breathe through
it breathe through it you'll feel the
difference like on the back of the neck
right here where it'll just like open up
just like crazy how much tension and
hold in our body that we don't need to
that we can let go of whoa yeah and I'm
still like iíve only been doing this for
and-a-half years and you know like the
Masters of this work like the Masters of
the lineage that I've taught me you know
have a minimum of
ten years of experience and so I feel
like there's still so much more you know
I feel like you know lineages thousands
of years of thousands of years of wisdom
and and I have just so much like
reverence for these for these plants and
for the wisdom that they have taught me
because I don't know anything you know
that's what the plants have taught
showed me everything and I'm really
really grateful to be able to share that
wisdom and to be able to you know be a
bridge for them to be be representative
and and I say that with humility you
know I'm grateful for that yeah the rock
itself is billions of years old and yeah
our little 25 50 year old yeah bands of
yeah we need its hefty dose of humility
is always in order just a crazy how much
of the you can actually feel in the in
the muscle and just a touch can do what
a lot of yeah of opening and integrating
and and just to be stuck in a that that
neurophysiological loop of of to trauma
versus being able to see it from an
observer and let it pass through it's
just wow you spoke about indigenous
briefly there I just I want to maybe
pass a little more time hearing from you
what it's been like you said the people
that you're learning from the lineage
have again you know even more
experienced than they're learning from
people again with even more experience
so it's this you know multi thousand
years of lineage what are indigenous
people like you were initially
mentioning at the beginning what are
they when you bring them into the the
like you or it's a gave us example at
Burning Man and stuff what are they
saying about what's happening with
Mother Earth and with the human race um
I think the most important message is
that what's happening there outside is
an expression of what's happening inside
and the reason that the earth is so much
of a mess is that you know symbolically
we have the Sun energy and the moon
energy and the Sun energy represents us
our external world and and how much we
we project our energy outside of
ourselves or when we're seeking or when
we're taking action and then the moon
energy is about how much are we pausing
and reflecting inwards and asking our
soul and connecting to our soul and
tuning into our intuition and connecting
to emotion and feeling our emotion and
there's a huge imbalance between the two
and so if we can't get back into balance
that's where our earth is is a huge
problem and if in what I found is this
connection between all of that for
instance the use of oil is fire energy
which is also connected with the Sun to
solar power plastics are connected to
solar use of money on credit cards is
the same thing so all of these behaviors
all these things we're indebting
ourselves and we're actually creating
toxicity in our body the you know we
look at all the plastic in the ocean we
look at all of the toxins in the air all
of these things our body is the exact
same thing and we can't say just because
we're richer or more privileged than
anybody else that we can separate
ourselves away even the people that that
don't have the privilege to be able to
buy an air purifier or take really good
supplements or drink really clean water
like we are them like we all are
receiving there's no way you can just
say oh I'm over here I'm just gonna take
my rocket ship to Mars and and separate
yourself from it there's there's no way
because it's internal and it's just
gonna keep recreating itself until we
saw
the problem internally Wow Wow yeah it's
this the this mirror this this
reflection of what we see that's an
issue some of the issues greatest issues
of our time externally are direct yeah
of what's happening internally I think
that's really profound and it actually
ties to solve the way to what you said
at the beginning as well about how
through these thousand plus people that
you've worked with that that there's a
mirror that's happening as well there's
like a lot of seeing what we see in
ourselves and other people across the
world of the issues around the world or
some of the issues within ourselves this
has been a very interesting conversation
and and I'm really grateful that you're
doing what you're doing in that yeah so
psychedelic journeys calm people can yes
yeah such an honors
you're amazing you're such an angel
plenty more please plenty more to come
soon yes yeah I want to I want to see if
we can get a quick question do you think
we're in a simulation yes I think the
word simulation has like the word itself
doesn't it misses the word love and love
is ultimately what this is about
but imagine this you are consciousness
just like I talked about these galactic
logos that are like a different flavor
of intelligence and love blend it
together in its own thing so imagine
that there's just one intelligence and
that one intelligence decides how it
would be really cool if I could
water-ski and eat food and have sex and
take psychedelics and swim in the ocean
and visit tropical islands
and and drink coconuts and all these
amazing things so it creates this world
by splitting itself the Big Bang it
splits itself into millions of pieces of
itself and those pieces are all a mirror
of the one and all of those as they
split apart have an identity a piece and
and that rainbow of intelligence comes
together and it creates a server let's
call it you know just just an overall
server of light and that server goes
through these different layers of
Galactic Intelligence Center Suns and
each one of them Suns is a portal and
eventually make it down to our planet
where it creates these archetypal
energies and that's basically what's
playing out is we have these archetypal
energies that basically are a encoding
of a software system it's it all is a
software system but the beauty of it is
the software system isn't a form of
slavery meaning that the machine is not
in service to the program but ultimately
love is the highest thing so once each
part of that individual program
recognizes that love is the secret then
they get to operate within the game with
complete sovereignty and they don't have
to actually play by the rules of the
game anymore although there are certain
rules within the game that always remain
consistent ok so the infinite
consciousness breaks up into all of the
pieces of the play lands and then we
remember that we are all part of that
and then we get to play by the sovereign
the sovereign game the sovereign which
is the game of love and it's so fun
because we created this paradise planet
which I've seen in the future it's a
paradise even this yeah it's so cool and
then we get to just do all these awesome
things and then when we get bored we can
go be a galactic logos
we can go do something else and
eventually you know the way it is is you
know like I all use the word God but God
meaning something different than Western
religion but this is God's toy box and
eventually all the toys will get packed
away in exactly the order that they came
in that's why all the energies are
ascending and they'll all get packed
together and then go back into source
and it's all coexisting at the same time
- toy box of God on this planet being
one of the toys and yes this illusion of
separation from the one that we get -
yeah and all the cool things that you
get to experience all the quality of it
gets to be experienced here it gets
packed in as we okay interesting yeah
okay okay and then what do you think and
so this is the break off of all the
infant consciousness into the into the
Big Bang you call that process
simulations I don't call it simulations
other people call it simulations okay
you know I I have my own like the way I
would describe it is very different than
that but I but I think it is like a game
it is like a simulation because there
are laws and you have to follow those
laws and you know many talk about karma
you know karma is a really important
part of that law if you understand how
karma works you will not suffer and
that's where you can learn to have the
freedom and learn to have the
sovereignty and be the one having the
fun in the game and being here for the
party yeah as in like not causing harm
on to others and there englander your
lifetime and that yeah and also your
past karma you know let the ancestral
karma as well so it's not just the Karma
it's karma that you've brought in as
well as not creating new Karma for
yourself
okay okay yes there's so much done
packed what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world love of
course yeah
love the divine I mean the beautiful
beautiful thing is when we get to
recognize the mystery of life when we
get to realize that everything that we
see no matter what it looks like is
actually something else that's all set
you have been the ultimate nature yeah
of the reality okay that's it Trisha
holy cow thank you so much for coming on
the show teaching us thank you medicines
yeah thank you to mother earth to this
playground that we get to our hideout I
know it's such a cool experience being
alive Wow okay thank you everybody for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking check out the
link in the bio to psychedelic journeys
calm and Trish's other links as well and
also get more conversations rollin with
our friends our family coworkers people
online on social media about what we
discuss in this episode and also check
out the links below to consciousness
hacking as well as the links below to
simulation support the organization's
the entrepreneurs the artists the
indigenous people around the world that
you believe in and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon
[Music]